[Music]
it's very interesting a family
immigrating to mexico rather than in the
other direction it's a novel
concept if you do what you're saying if
you cross the border you're going to die
you and your kids are going to die the
more i like
the characters that i'm writing the more
peril i want to expose them to
you want to see what any given character
is gonna do in a given situation
you need to drink
you're no good to the kids if you're
dead in the desert
this has been a really hard shoot
there's one way of shooting a show which
is
on sound stages in burbank you want it
to look like the desert you drive a
little bit out of la
this is wildly different we're actually
going to all these different places and
it's so diverse
it was just so exciting we're kind of
having a similar experience to the foxes
themselves which is
it started in california shooting that
oh that's lovely and we went to
this border town of mexicali to shoot
some of the desert episode
that has this enormous scope and this
enormous
canvas we often have often
have nightmares thinking about that
episode we had a fantastic
director that just put us through hell
because that's what they were going
through and that's what they decided
they would do to us so
we eat cactus fruit and that's thirsty
and
sleeping in a bus don't do that
moisture makes it worse it surrounds us
in the environment that our characters
are in
i definitely think that it kind of bonds
us as a group and makes us seem more
like a family
when you're sweating you're really
sweating you know when you're cold
you're really cold when you're hot
you're really hot
hopefully that translates in the show
itself
[Music]
you